hello hello and welcome
another live stream in which we are
going to continue our journey to solve
project Euler challenges so far we solve
22 problems or challenges or however
however you want to call them and if
we're going to solve the well all of the
100 ones in the project order one have
the challenge then we are almost a
quarter away right hopefully today we
are going to get problem 25 and solve it
we'll see
hello everyone say hi in the chat if
your life and we can start with problem
23 let's see what this says non abundant
abundant sums all right that's an
interesting word a perfect number is a
number for which the sum of its proper
divisors is exactly equal to the number
for example the sum of the proper
divisors of 28 would be 1 2 4 7 and 14
added up which is 28 all right so that
means 28 is a perfect number good a
number n is called deficient if the sum
of its proper divisors is less than n
and it's called abundant if the sum
exceeds all right so then the perfect is
equals right then deficient is less and
abundant is higher all right good
as 12 is the smallest abundant number so
for which the sum of its divisors is
bigger than a number right we have 1 2 3
4 & 6 to be 16 the smallest number that
can be written as the sum of 2 abundant
numbers is 24 all right so 24 to
abundant number that means 12 and 12
right okay
by mathematical analysis it can be shown
that all integers greater than 20
thousand 123 can be written as the sum
of the two abundant numbers what can be
written as sum of 12 on numbers alright
so let's see again all integers greater
than oh okay that's interesting
however this upper limit cannot be
reduced any further by analysis even
though it is known that the greatest
number that cannot be expressed as the
sum of two abundant number is less than
this limit yeah so this is why I'm
reading out everything this is pretty
interesting and probably a little
confusing all right let's see again so
this upper limit cannot be reduced any
further by analysis even though it is
known that the greatest number that can
that cannot be expressed the sum of the
abundant numbers is less than this limit
all right let's see what we need to find
the sum of all possible positive
integers less or equal than n which were
given here which cannot be written as
the sum of two abundant numbers
okay so they sounds complicated all
right so we have to do a lot of
calculations well let's let's see so we
need to go over all the numbers from 1
to N right so let's write it down pretty
confusing this one yeah a lot on to the
right I actually take it took a look
before in the stream just to see what we
have to do and it got me confused there
but let's see we already for those of
you who joined for the first time this
is what how we roll all right reading
the text then we're solving it by
solving small pieces the time right and
then we unite those pieces and hopefully
it works well we got so far so hopefully
we'll get further we'll see all right so
is 1 then I less than equal to n I plus
plus right good so we have that which is
a good start
ok so let's see again find the sum of
all positive integers which cannot be
written as a sum of two abundant numbers
all right so what we know that an
abundant number has the sum of its
divisors bigger than a number right all
right now we kind of need to go over all
the numbers let's think so find the sum
of all positive integers which can be
written as a sum so already when you say
some there are two numbers right when
it's at numbers and
some of the numbers from 1 to n cannot
be written as a sum of two abundant
numbers but for that we need to see all
bonded numbers right which could
potentially be added to get that number
does it make sense it kind of makes in
my mind but yeah it's it's it's
confusing a bit all right let's see we
will need a function which will give us
all the divisors right we did this a
couple of times so let's let's do it
again
I guess let's put this here and let's
see how we did it get divisors and we
pass in a number and here let's see we
go up to half of it right 1 2 4 7 14 yet
so forth let I equals 1 I less than
number divided by 2 I plus plus and
we're going to create a div Visser's
array all right and we're going to
return this tvs are three like that and
here we're going to do if number modulus
I is zero then it means the peas are and
we're going to push it here they feel
sort push I all right so at least one
thing it's done now we need to see if it
is abundant so function let's see how
we're going to do it we're going to give
this function the number and the
divisors we're going to add the visitors
and we're going to compare it to the
number right so he is abundant
let's think so is abundant the number we
can just pass in the number actually
let's not pass the divisors and here
we're going to get a divisor so Const
the deserts will be get abusers of the
number I said that let's say number
let's be consistent here number alright
oops I had all right sorry I had I had
the wrong overlay my back
that's the overlay from my own Street
all right good
but yeah give these life signal like
anyway and feel free to support the
pre-cut cap if we go camp channel by
becoming a member by donating I can I
think you can do that yeah all right
good close the parentheses there so what
we did here we got the divisors and now
let's see we need to have the sum so the
sum will be divisors and let's use the
good old reduce accumulator number
emulator plus number and 0 so this goes
over all the numbers in the divisors and
as them all up in this accumulator and
and returns it yet so now what we want
to do is to see if sum is greater than
number if it is then this number is
abundant right get get get get get so we
did that
we're one step closer now let's see
again find the sum of all positive
integers which cannot be written as the
sum of two abundant numbers okay now
what I'm thinking
[Music]
you
we somehow need to store all of these
abundant numbers and let's see
[Music]
thinking
okay so we need to go over the numbers
from 1 to N
this song so we're going to need two
numbers from the abundant array which
you don't have yet but we're going to
create and if we cannot find a sum then
we will store that number okay let's see
but how about the Sun so these sums we
could I'm thinking in order to store the
abundant numbers we could use an array
we could use an object which is a set
I'm thinking I'm going to use an array
so let's see abundant numbers will be an
empty array and we're going to go over
all of these numbers and we're going to
check if it's an abundant number
although I'm not sure if we should go
over all of them but let's see
hello our pan welcome how are you today
okay
if is abundant we have this function
right he's abundant he's abundant I then
we wanted to abundant I guess and that's
a long name but hello
push pie and let's return this abundant
numbers let's see what we get
I want to console the clock
yes
all right abundant number 36 why we
don't have 12 so that's an itch already
hmm
okay don't like this is it because there
are a lot of numbers here No
so something something is wrong
let's see what's the output of calling
console that log is abundant tough we
know that that should be right because
it says here and well it's logical for
it to be let's see it's false okay so
that's not good let's see the divisors
DB source
one two three six
KIC we went from one up to number
divided by two
but we need two equals here all right
good so now that will work properly good
we don't need this anymore all right
look at that so now these are all the
bundle numbers
which is interesting to say the least we
don't have any bundle number above 1,400
that's weird
let's see
okay it's somehow weird right but I
guess all right so we have all these
abundant numbers now
as I said that none don't know exactly
if we should go over all the numbers
here and to create a banner numbers from
them but now what I want to do is to
create an interesting loop this is not
the most optimal way to do it but
hopefully it will work said every
programmer ever
[Music]
we want to go over these numbers and
then go through the bundle numbers array
and check all them to see well add them
up
let's see so we want to add them up to
see if we have that number
or we could do something else I just had
an idea
we know that we need to find the sum of
two abundant numbers right and we have
an array of those about numbers so what
if instead of going over all the numbers
and checking of the array again to find
the sum what if we create the array of
the sum of the Bunin numbers does that
make sense
so let's here let me write this down
maybe that would make sense then add up
lengths so we go over all of these twice
this will be still less than doing this
basically every time we go over the
numbers from here
okay
and we basically want to add them up
in another array so we have bundle
numbers come some of bundled yeah it's a
weird okay let's see
Let X be abundant numbers of I and left
Y the abundant numbers so we get two
numbers from this abundant array and we
add them up so sum of abundant that push
X plus y so we basically now have all
the subs right and the last thing to do
is to go over this array those are these
numbers from 1 to N and check if we have
if we don't have the Sun because we have
to find the sum of all positive integers
which cannot be written as a sum of two
abandon numbers all right I feel like
we're getting closer but let's see one
thing I feel we'll have in this is that
we'll have a lot of duplicate numbers
which is I guess fine
not a number here
[Music]
that's not good
and it broke the browser here let me not
counsel this for now
let's optimize this pit so comes some I
guess we could just cross here it'll be
X plus y if some let's see
some of abundant includes so if it
includes already
don't want that it so if it's not
included we want to push it so basically
now we're sure that we won't have the
number twice right band and why do they
have to be so weird my mates
okay
is this a way we can speed this up a bit
so we're getting all the bundle numbers
and then we adding them up
King
what if when we get an abundant number
we add we added up with all the numbers
already here
we away so we don't do this again but
let's go with it for now
let's hope that this won't break
maybe we can test with smaller numbers
like thousand all right and now
hopefully we don't have duplicate
numbers we still have not a number which
is weird
why is that
we should only have numbers
okay so we get number from there we do
the sum
number is not a number some I want to
console that vlog
X Y and some I want to see where is that
not a number
sorry one dad
well I want to run that list
okay twelve undefined eighteen undefined
what's the index
zero 246
okay so act why is undefined
this is weird
why is that why we have undefined
index two four six
the last one
yeah 2:46 is the last one
but why we cut that
if it's abundant
we push
and we push and find
oh that's why we go up to the inclusive
alright good good gets it we find the
bug and we squished it yet so now that's
done
we shouldn't see not the number now
which is good we're one step closer all
right
get so these are basically all the sums
a lot of time
what we want now we're getting closer
let's see so what we won now find the
sum of all positive integers less than n
which cannot be written
as the sum of two abundant numbers
so we go over the numbers right from 1
to N and if that number is not in this
array then we want to add them up to a
song right I think that's let's see
let's sum 0 well actually let me put it
here for let I again 1 I less than
we're going to optimize this a bit
eventually I less than equal to n so
over all of the numbers I plus plus and
here if we don't have it in the sum of
abundant so pretty much anything like
this here it doesn't think it's not
included then we want some plus equals I
and we want returned it son
right so something's not Oh
all right we're getting a number that's
not the number we want
the tests maybe there yeah
time out alright alright a lot of loops
here which is not good we need to
optimize this
and the idea from the chat
okay so
you
today today to do
could this oops look at this here that's
one improvement
I think so if we had abundant numbers
and then we do this
okay
[Music]
let's see let's ban don't be and find
and if this is abundant then abandoned
well bi and let's see why did they do
this I want I still want to push it but
if we have abundant
over the abundant numbers so let's
abandon numbers push band and
I guess I can do this here okay
now I want to go over abundant numbers
numbers for each number and I want to do
the sum here sum of abundant that push
naam plus abundant right so we kind of
create some here pretty much what we do
here right X will be the abundant number
and Y will be the bundle all the bundle
numbers from the sum we already sorry
abundant numbers here oh yeah that's
good this abundant numbers alright so
now we should not need this but then
again this could be done here so we push
the number
I guess we don't dis then we can use I
so we push the I and when we push it we
go over all of them and we add them up
inside to create a sum of abundance and
we can do also this to check if we don't
have it already
do we need to do that this will kind of
go over all the numbers
worse adding more number at having
duplicate numbers or going over the
array to check all of the numbers and
don't push it otherwise I guess this
will slow it down a bit
and then we're already going here over
let's see how this improves it the
bundle is not defined okay number sorry
all right we don't get a good number now
but let's see if it still times out if
it is then oh yeah then we're still not
good at doing a very good job
staking a lot where can we improve
you
like key
and ideas in the chat don't leave me
maybe someone
last time I did a extreme summer reached
out to me and Facebook to tell me you
did run there so you can do that
alright this card I'm thinking how can
we improve this
you
like we could save some time
this up there because basically were but
we don't have all the sums
how many numbers do we have here ban
hamma ban on the length
Oh
that many numbers what if we do this
will that help
I've come some num plus I and then we do
this
whoa
that helps a bit that helps a bit Oh
from 1689 Sam's
and thousand that's a bit all right so
then let's leave this there the idea
should be the same
how the number changes infinite loop
online eight
oh well
I don't like this here
yeah let's see still times out no not
good
we have a loop here we have another loop
here
yes
here's the thing we can simplify here we
get the divisors and here we add them up
why not have the sum of the desserts
[Music]
well I guess let's move this and here
we're going to create a sum we save some
loops it's all about performance now sum
is zero and if it's divisible than sum
plus equals I so then we don't need this
and we don't need this and we don't need
this
right so we just check if it is at his
or right here
and thinking how could we check our
performances
still turned out
perfect
so
okay
there are a lot of numbers that's why
Oh oops
oops we need to return some here
but I guess it's still time doubt but
still at least we don't have the link
there
else
you
one thing I noticed and maybe we can use
is that you saw how many abundant
numbers we had which were under well
less than 10,000
abundant numbers
that flank
339 numbers and when we go to to 20,000
10:41 that's not good
maybe the wicked competitor is messing
with us again or is it maybe not
should
yeah Candace back here
it's weird that always in the stream the
first one is the hardest
all right you can see how this name
number changes so it's probably not
you know what let's get this code and
let's run it in vs code which should be
about faster and well at least we can
see what we get right so let me open
this NBS code
well it won't be timed out the worst
will break the Mac but we've been there
scripted yes
if it breaks just be patient I'll be
back it happened once so hopefully it
won't happen again
all right and now let's go with small
number just to see how well it works
node script the GS
alright okay so that's good
that's the lacked at least let me do
something note man scrape Jas - Q so
this will run always whenever we save
alright now let me put this to the right
oh it's fine
what about ten thousand
yep
so this takes a while
you
you
each
sad
do we have some mistakes somewhere this
is why it's not faster who knows
just trying to see what's happening here
yeah that's definitely not fast
okay
I don't know how we can improve this
so getting to be abundant we need to get
all the desires and to well check if the
sum is greater so
yeah look at how much it took to do all
that
it was something to test let's see
console that time
you
you
you
the name of the timer I just want to see
how well fast it is get so time and time
and so on so that time Hey
well started and we're going to run it
again your console that time end
let's put bigger camp okay and let's run
it with last numbers
okay call milliseconds that's good
let's see 3000
what
that's faster
yes
something's wrong with that
alright that's about 10,000
oh whoops whoops here is where I want to
have it after it calls the function
right my bad
all right 29:34 3741 33 good but about
3000 now
all right now this is more likely
okay you can see that 600 ish if we have
5000 will it be let's see so for
a thousand was 33 so should yeah that
felt right
that times the amount so this is five
seconds
three seconds and for ten thousand well
it will be
yeah it shouldn't be double or triple
because we have more numbers and it
needs to calculate between more numbers
all right in the meantime let's see
let's do small adjustments and see if we
can sort of improve it
step-by-step and eventually have it well
be submitted or at least
oh we could at least see if we have the
correct number right what is it
so for ten thousand we need this number
oh yeah but we're not doing the sum here
so let's this son
three seconds oh yeah yes let's see
we're going over the numbers we check if
it's abundant if it is we push it to
this array and then we go over the array
and we get the sums
right because we need to see if that
number is in between some
you know when you start to go on a path
you kind of don't see other paths though
maybe this is where I'm stuck now three
seven three one zero zero four three
seven three one zero four so at least we
know we have the correct answer but now
we just need to speed it up all right
yeah at least we have the characters
they should work but the time out can we
use
this statement which I don't understand
however this upper limit cannot be
reduced any further by analysis even
though it is known that the greatest
number that cannot be expressed as the
sum of two banner numbers is less than
this limit
okay
so the greatest number that cannot be
expressed is less and not sure if that
tells us
to create this number that cannot be
expressed is less yeah okay doesn't help
I think does it Lauren where are you
you're my you're the Joey to my
Chancellor or the otherwise all right
yes so it takes 33 seconds
which is a lot a lot of numbers
what else do we know
[Music]
one loop another look
yeah
another loop
well-well-well they speed up let's let's
try it with 3000 let's run it a couple
of times and see how much we get
right around 6:00
let's write it down for three thousand
is round six
I know sixty six ninety six thirty
yeah all right around that what if we
don't day so we just push
okay look at that so you can see that
it's faster is the same thing with more
numbers
you
this is if way
check
for 3,000 is round
and read if we don't check all right
maybe using a catch like a dick to store
the numbers he's a thief abundant like
in bull if the numbers in the cache you
don't need to check for TV source
wait a second for deserves
but we we don't so we just get the
number
you
we get the numbers diffusers
well I kind of have one idea we could
spit up things although I'm not sure how
much what would work we kid a check here
if sum is greater
but I'm not sure how that will work
because if we go up to half of it
how many divisors could have
12 has the most and only the last one
yeah that won't help
alright let's continue this this pad so
for five thousand we have let's run two
more times
1.6 1.5 1.9 all right that's not good
yeah I guess
if we don't check and if we check just
died trying to find little things to
speed it up
well look at that difference so if we
check well it's a lot more
because is that function is abundant got
called every time
but don't ya
I know we kind of check all the numbers
if they are abundant which we shouldn't
really because we all need to get the
sums
all right so we know they've done in
only laughs we don't need to check it's
faster that way
so 10,000 should be faster now
last time it was 30 so minutes sorry
seconds where it was
we had the correct answer somewhere
here yeah 33 seconds
yeah these are just small clicks I'm not
sure 20 seconds so that's all but so ah
good don't like this
always goes and it checks I don't want
to do that how fast will it
be whoa
[Music]
whoa no dad's fast
basically we go over
disarray 10,000 times
this is where they [ __ ] right now how
can we check it's not included all right
I have another idea
we can use an object so some of well I
guess somewhat abundant old be an object
and
some of abundant of some will just be
set through or whatever so now we have
an object where the property is the
number and the values true so we don't
do this we don't do this and so let me
show you what's the sum abundant now how
it looks like the last numbers obviously
look at that see so we basically have
all the numbers here this is probably
faster way so now instead of doing this
we just need to check if some of
abundant
of I write if it's true well if it's not
true
then we add it up to the Sun
does it make sense so we get the sum
there in the sum of abundance and it
will be set it through and now if this
number is not there then it means that
it cannot be written as a sum of two
abundant so then we added up to what the
final saw a lot of sums a lot of things
that's it well look at how fast that is
now
okay this should this should be now the
way although one thing we could do here
is be false and that remove this so if
it is in disarray then it falls it's not
well it can be written as a sum and we
don't want to add it up for the final
countdown all right let's see how fast
is now for ten thousand look at that
it's fast but it's not right why it's
zero
if some abundant of I
oh I guess it's undefined it sounded
fine then we added alright look at that
whoo this was hard let's copy this over
and still taking a lot but finally way
did it oh boy let's say
this was hot how long it took
Inc it to the web
you can't see a timer here anymore but
how long have been extreme Oh for almost
an hour
whoa yeah
so that was the issue we were going over
a raise to check if it's inside and
that's pretty slow so just checking the
object I guess a set could do but I
don't know exactly after you set that
well so we're doing the object trick
Thank You Larry all right
let me remove this and this
and yeah
okay I guess this could be set to pretty
much anything if it's not in there so
it's undefined then you want to
to be done all right Sammy tango good
[Laughter]
no permutations ouch this is hard oh but
well at least we're closer to at least
doing 25 problems
Lex lexicographic permutation x' a
permutation is an ordered arrangement of
objects for example 3 1 2 4 is one
possible permutation of the digits 1 2 3
4 if all of the permutations are list
numerically or alphabetically
we call it lexographic
order the last lexographic permutations
of 1 2 & 1 0 & 2 are well-pleased
what is the end lexicographic
permutation of the digits
this
okay
[Laughter]
we're busted I don't know I remember
always googling how to do permutations
okay and also need to have them in order
and look at how many numbers there
Emilia
okay
pretty fun these challenges are getting
harder harder
it's a classical interview question for
Google I believe yep probably so I guess
I won't be hired by Google then
you
how we're going to do this 0 1 2 0 2 1 1
0 2 1 0
two zero one two one zero all right this
is four three zero one two three zero
zero one three two
zero what's the next
what's the next
3 - 2 - 1 0 2 3 1 0 3 2 0 3 1 2 0 3 2 1
and then all of these again wait 1 in
front
looks like a recursive function to me
yeah I know it is recursive function
the table
let's think I don't know how we did it
so
you
when do we know when to swap
you
if we would have all the permutations
then while it will be easy right we just
get the end here
this
take another hour
and not the best recursive functions
hah and trying to remember how we did
should we just look for how to do it
and for some reason failed it's cheating
with
the permutations
and they also have to be in order
you
you
take your time this is fun yeah fun
watching probably I bet it's fun for you
[Music]
curse now how can we move this to the
right and then
a kiss first
what's the logic here
zero zero zero zero zero zero
1 1 1 1 1 1 2 2 2 2 2
zero
so we prepped here we have two six six
numbers times 4 right - 24 permutations
here we have so this is 24 here we have
6 what's the Matt here
I think one times two times three
one times two times three times now
there is a ho doesn't matter how many
they are we need to find the end one
look at this
we have here zeroes
one's and then his twos look at how we
have here to add them well the millionth
almost the millionth number is to here
so we probably have
million permutations
for the
one element is that element like a
returns a with two characters you can
serve the second char before and after
the a so you have two permutations okay
but what's next let's let's read about
let's see what we could use
- loosely speaking an arrangement of its
numbers okay we know what it is how can
we find it
you
you
okay
you
you
in random we could random them up until
we have them out that'll be fun
you
generational in a lexical order oh okay
this is text we can read it maybe we'll
get an idea this is not cheating right
there are many ways to systematically
generate our permutation of a given
sentence segments let me zoom in here
one classic simple and flexible
algorithm is based upon finding the next
permutation in lexicographic order if it
exists it can handle repeated values for
which case it generates each distinct
multiset prepetition ones even for
ordinary permutations it is
significantly more efficient than
generating values for the Lamar code in
EXO graphic order
possibly using the factorial number
system and converting those to
permutations it begins by sorting the
sequence in weekly increasing order
which gives it's like lexicographical in
minimal permutation and then repeats
advancing to the next permutation as
long as one is found the method goes
back to narayana pandita sorry if I
mispronounced your name 14th century
India and has been rediscovered
frequently let's see the following
algorithm generates the next permutation
vector graphically after given after a
given permutation it changes the given
permutation in place
look into the factorial number system
well so we're learning here it's not
cheating we're learning you can use this
okay find the largest index K such that
a of K is less than a of K plus 1
if no such index exists the fermentation
is the last fermentation
okay you lost in the first but okay it's
a crap oh I think I know find the
largest index L greater than K such that
a of K less than eval
swap the values of a of k with that of a
of L reverse the sequence from a k plus
1 up to and including the final amount a
of n okay let's see we have an example
for example given the sequence which is
an increasing order and given that the
index is 0 based the steps ours are
false index K of 2 the K equals 2
because 3 is placed that an index that
certifies the condition of being the
largest index that is still less than a
k plus 1 which is 4
all right index L equals 3 because 4 is
the only value the sequence is the
greater than 3 in order to satisfy the
condition
the values of a 3 & 8 a 2 & a 3 are
swapped to form a new sequence
the sequence after K index
to the final element is reversed
oh the sequence after K minus index a to
editor's NYK - index
all right so the final event is reversed
because only one value lies after they
index the three the sequence remain
unchanged in this distance that's the
leg lexographic successor of the initial
state is permitted
following this algorithm the next liquid
graphic the permutation will be 1 3 2 4
why
[Laughter]
and largest index case such that largest
in this case is that half K less than
so what's now here
index k death no such that a of K is
less than afk
No
[Laughter]
okay
at which point a of K less than 8 K plus
1 does not exist
you
you
find the largest okay I think I
[Music]
see it which is hard to follow yeah
so we find the largest K which is three
here because well we can go we need to
have a k plus one which will be 4
yet when we found that we also need an
of L which will be well this needs to be
greater so it will be for this case and
we swap them right ok now we have this
here we find 2 to be well largest
for
[Music]
and then L will be three again
the largest integer greater than cases
that yeah
and we swapped them
but that's not true right in the
sequence after K minus index
reverse the sequence from a k plus 1 up
to and including the final program
element
oh I think I say
this one so as I said this
all these properties
and then we'll reverse them 4 2 3 4 2 3
1
No I still it is hot let's see why I
said to look into factorial number
system
[Music]
a lot of pretty stuff here permutations
no idea
well we kind of have the algorithm we
just need to implement it
largest case there's a day of cases in a
K plus-1 no such indexes is the
permutation is the last rotation find
the largest index L greater than K such
that a of K less than 800 so we go from
the right we go from the hole
I'm thinking
the largest queso
I still don't and fully understand how
we went from this to this if we can find
out them I think we're done if that's a
big if
okay find the largest index L greater
than K such that is it on the right okay
yeah
I find the largest index al greater than
K such that Oh
so yeah I was right there we swap these
two
the sequence from a K plus-1
which is the
so up the valleys
then if we swap them it will count this
will be the one which was swapped or
it's the one which will be up to and
including the final element
so for some reason okay let's let's
write it down
so we have one two three four we go here
we find the largest which is well
second-to-last likely like well and this
one and we go one two four three now
will be this K will be this what we're
doing with our by the way yeah we're
swapping them good now that's the first
thing next we get this this is K this is
K plus 1 and this is K well
and we
welp them so it will be one for two
three but then it does this reverse the
sequence from a k plus 1 up to and
including the final element so I think
this one now
one when we inverse them three to four
right let's find let's see if we managed
to find the correct next element then
your goal
uhh
[Music]
test
the largest case is a take a less than a
k plus one so what's the largest three
now
all this is not the don't doesn't go
there
so three now
and then the largest L greater than K
such that a k less a of K is less than a
of L
for
we swapped them on four to three and
then we reverse
from K plus 1
these reverse thing is not familiar to
me
although I but looking at it it should
be 1 3 4 - right
we get to death probably this is our
ending the project Euler charge
they're just well more likely to be even
harder than harder
you
can we find something else
okay
let's read more
maybe maybe maybe I don't understand
that
right for some reason although I have
everything they're not sure if you do if
you do and then let me know if you do
let's see permutations in lexo graphical
order
yeah I feel like
you
all right let's look at this this eye
feels a bit better so
so the given string and non-decreasing
order and printed the first fermentation
is always a string sorted in non
decreasing order start generating next
higher permutation do it until next
higher permutation is not possible if we
reach a permutation where all craft is
assorted in non increasing order then
that permutation is the last get steps
to generate the next higher permutation
take the previously printed permutation
and find the rightmost character in it
which is smaller than its next character
let us call this character is the first
character so something similar write
that K we had
where are you
[Music]
okay so find the largest cases that yeah
so it's second to second to largest okay
now find the ceiling of the first
character ceiling is the smallest
character on the right the smallest
largest index greater than K okay so
then I don't see them being the same
here
now find the ceiling of the first
character ceiling is the smallest
character on the right of first
character
have changed
so a lot of missing the factorial number
system if you have one two three the
total permutations are n factorial which
is six so if you see the permutations of
two and three are and
after being too
you will have a change on the left most
digit after two permutations
Oh
I think I see we're going
two three one two two equals change one
change to one three
yeah kind of see where you're going but
still I don't know how to apply it
let's see again here find the ceiling of
the first connector seeing is the
smallest character of on right of first
character which is greater than first
director let us call the co character
the second character
swap the two characters found in a buff
step sort the substring in um this
creasing border after the original index
of first character
sort
let us consider the string ABCDEF let
previously printed permutation of the DC
EF e ba the next permutation is sorted
out order should be d e ABC f
let us understand above steps voila the
first character will be C C path ok the
second character will be e
why isn't it
smallest character on right of first
character which is a greater where is e
on the right here
it's f on the right okay after swapping
this - we got d e f CBA
you
what
you
does anyone understand what they're
doing here
first character is C the second
character is E
for swapping the two we got
so swapping this with this isn't it DC a
BEF
the final step is so disappearing after
the character ya know
get it alright let's go back to what he
said so you know the leftmost character
going from zero to one in the sequence
change it after counting nine
nine factorial of nine is it factorial
or just exclamation mark yeah I see here
the implementation but I won't look
okay
a lot things here
you
one second
so I know the left-most character going
from zero to one in the sequence change
it after counting nine factorial
by Alex and what did I do in the mean in
those well meantime
I don't know
okay introduction previously permutation
oh this is while coding I don't want to
get cut just copy paste code I want to
understand the logic behind it I don't
boiler problem 24 this is what we have
to do so yeah no no no
okay
recorder
man
you
hmm so 0 1 2 3 will change to 1 after 3
factorial which are 6 characters so then
2 will change after 1 factorial
will change after
zero one two three
after three factorial right which is 6
this will change after 2 factory which
is 2
this will change after
well this will change these two were
always changing right
so 0 1 3 2 and then 2 factorial now
these changes and changes with the last
one right right
0 2 these changes with this one say this
is what I don't get
changing but to what they should be here
let me look at the next one maybe we
take a break from this one
1000 digits Fibonacci number
what's the index of the first term in
the Fibonacci sequence to contain n
digit
you
yeah I guess this will be easier let's
do this and I'm going to
learn more about fermentations and we're
going to do it next week okay
just addresses them get it now
[Music]
so Fibonacci is well for those of you
don't know we get to start with one and
one and then the next number will be
that previous two numbers added up so 1
+ 1 - 2 + 1 3 3 + 2 5 and so on and so
forth
sorry Laurent I missed ya
let's let's do this one seems easier
Fibonacci the 12th or f12 is the first
time to contain three digits
what's the index of the first term in
the Fibonacci sequence to contain n
digits alright so we need to add the
Fibonacci numbers up and we need to get
the digits and when we get the first
number to be two-digit we just yell it
out
oh we all doubt the index yeah it's a
tough one although if you know
permutations then shouldn't be the tough
but alright okay so let's see what
functions do we need I need the function
to
[Music]
calculate digits and we get the number
let's call it an and we return and plus
we convert it to a string all right
guess we could say to string that lect
all right and here we start with let's
see let a be one let B be one and let
index be
to
and while
while to don't do this
while too
let temp or well I guess you can stamp B
a a B
sorry not sorry
okay so we store be yeah a
okay I'm losing it now B equals B plus a
and a equals B right so the next one
will be the previous two and a equals
temp not be this is why we store it
alright and index plus plus if get
digits get digits count if get digits
count of B equals and then we return
index
all right how how can be this so easy
and then the previous one so hard how I
don't understand I really don't
understand
okay
as I said if you know permutations then
well it's not part but yeah I know I
don't like having all this all than this
one not be solved
nine factorial is 360 2880 so and item
in the sequence will have the digits
zero
at the beginning because did not change
for at many numbers
and trying to see what Lauren is saying
here
I understand what you mean but how can I
use that
because I don't see that okay
you
k-stew because three is placed the next
certified condition of being the largest
index
that is less than a Custer which is four
okay
now history because
the sequence is created entry in order
to satisfy the condition a K less than a
how the values of a to a of two and a
half there swap from the from this week
sequence
sequence after k-
I don't see this K - index K of index
to the final element is reversed because
only one value lies after this index the
three the sequence remain unchanged in
this instance
that's the lexographic successor of the
assist LT is permeated
sequence from a K plus-1
including the final element so basically
tastes fun
you
you
[Music]
you
order of all permutations of n equals
length of N equals 4 generated by
different algorithms the permutations
are color code color coded where one is
red with yellow trees green four is blue
you
yeah
you
you
all right I don't know what to do
we should we continue this next
some reason so yeah
we also need to implement it so we need
to go over the Ray if we have an array
right and we need to find this condition
then find the largest index L greater
than K such that then we need to find
this condition yeah all right I'm going
to stop here
I'm going to read more about it and then
we're going to it next week
I'm sorry about that but
I just don't get it now oh well what
else we have here
this looks also funny
yeah numbers all right thank you for
watching sorry I couldn't finish that
one maybe you could which is perfect let
me know you can DM me well you can email
me or you can join the discord and we
can talk there but they couldn't figure
out now but I will somehow someday thank
you for watching I wish you have a great
day and I'll see you next time bye